hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
i o test myeloid activation cd169pe
hla drapc cd64
pb antibody cocktail visualizing immune
response during infections
i am jennifer woods of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann culture life sciences to
learn more
visit beckman.com let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i now present today's speaker dr shankar
potti robin pati i'm so sorry
hatab iraman dr shankar patabhi raman
technical
product manager for the flow cytometry
business unit
with beckman culture life sciences for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
shankar you may now begin your
presentation
hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
shankar patabhirama
and i am a technical product manager
with the global flow cytometry business
unit
at beckman culture life sciences today i
would like to talk to you about
our new assay iotas myeloid activation
and how we can use this to visualize the
immune response
during infections
next is a standard disclaimer for
intellectual
properties
bacterial which is viral to treat or not
to treat is the question
why is this so important differentiating
between
the natures of infection can allow
health care
providers deliver quicker and more
accurate
treatments antibiotics are effective
only against bacteria
and not and are not useful in the cases
of viral infections
such as colds bloom and more sore
throats
due to the lack of rapid and good tests
to differentiate
bacterial infections there is a tendency
to prescribe
antibiotics erroneously the case of
viral infections or excessively
antibiotics have saved millions of lives
and have contributed to a significant
increase
in the expectancy and the quality of
life
but the overuse or the misuse of
antibiotics
returns to create a global problem of
antibiotic resistant
bacterial pathogens this is a
significant threat
to the public health system and comes at
great
cost in terms of life and money
the main challenge in the effective
discrimination between bacterial and
vital infections
is that the clinical features presented
such as
fever cold pain are generic to both of
them
microbiological tests that is the
culture of bacteria
in vitro are dependent upon the
accessibility to the infection site
sampling efficiency and the time to
result can be long
one to three days which makes treatment
problematic
there are many molecular tests available
for the diagnosis of viral and bacterial
infections
many are even point of care however
these are available only for a small set
of infections
further prior knowledge of the
microorganism
is required to develop a new molecular
test
like the sequence information it makes
new pathogens difficult to diagnose
current protein and immunological tests
like
crp procalcitonin and cytokines
have no sensitivity and specificity
thus there is a need for an effective
rapid and easy screening test
infectious diseases are caused by the
invasion of the body by microorganisms
upon infection these are rapidly
recognized
and eliminated by the innate immune
system
which is the first line of defense
against pathogens
and reacts within hours myeloid cells
such as dendritic cells monocytes and
macrophages and neutrophils
are activated upon contact with the
foreign bodies
and microbial patterns their recognition
by the innate immune cells leads to the
initiation of a robust
inflammatory response including the
release of various
pro-inflammatory mediators such as
cytokines and interferons
and the recruitment and the activation
of other myeloid cells
the innate immune cells provide an early
however non-specific response to
infections
taking place within the first 12 to 24
hours of the infection the myeloid
cells then activates the slower but more
specific and effective cells of the
adaptive
immune system the adaptive immunity
which is required for the long term
sustained response to infection
is activated through the classical
mhc-tcr interaction
with the activated dendritic cells
interferons are cytokines secreted by
variety of cells upon infection
inflammation and autoimmune diseases
and have immunomodulatory effects
interferons are at the crossroads of the
two systems
as they are essential not only for the
innate immunity
but also for the activation and
sustenance of the adaptive immunity
during bacterial infections it is
predominantly the type 2 interferon
interferon gamma which is secreted by
the encases
upon activation by the dendritic cell
il-12
viral infections on the other hand lead
to the production
specifically of type 1 enterprise such
as interferon alphas and betas
thus interferon signaling also at the
crossroad in the immune
innate immune response as it is able to
differentiate
between infections by bacteria and
viruses
however direct measurement of
interferons is a challenge
the short-lived nature of interferon
make direct measurements difficult
however interferon signaling pathways
can be observed by the downstream genes
and the markers
activated by this molecules part of an
immune imprint of interferon signaling
several cell surface markers are
specifically activated
on myeloid cells upon the secretion of
intercoms
ideal markers of interferon response to
infection
would be specific to viruses and
bacteria
helping to differentiate between the two
this is the case for monocyte
cd 169 and neutrophil cd64
interferon type 1 interferon alpha and
from beta specifically upregulate the
expression of cd169 on monocytes
and the specific for viral infections
type 2 interferons that is interferon
gamma
specifically upregulates the expression
of cd64
on neutrophils which is specific for
bacterial infections
the specific differential markers of
infection
and interferon signaling are cd169
and cd64 we have also included
hladr as an indicator of the immune
status
to the assay platform
td 64 or fc gamma receptor 1 is
constitutively present
on macrophages monocytes esophages
and only to a small extent on resting
neutrophils however neutrophil cd64
expression rapidly increases in the
presence of
bacterial cell wall components and some
pro-inflammatory cytokines
such as interferon gamma and granulocyte
colony stimulating factor in gccsm
neutrophil cd64 expressions have been
reported
in many bacterial diseases showing it to
be a
potentially useful early biomarker
for detection of bacterial infection and
sepsis with high sensitivity and
specificity
the ct-169 cyclic 1 gene expression
is induced by type 1 interferons on
myeloid cells such as
monocytes and dendritic cells
recently cd169 has been identified as an
inducible viral attachment factor on
myeloid dendritic cells
td 6169 is not constitutively expressed
and the induction on monocytes of this
marker has been shown in a number of
different viral infections such as hiv
epsilon bar virus and the type 1
interferon expression
monocytic cd169 has been shown to be a
biomarker of hiv infection
and disease progresses further it was
shown
that antiretroviral therapy led to a
decrease
in the monocytic cd169 corresponding to
the decrease
in the viral load
monocytic hladr an activation marker
is upregulated in acute infections both
viral
and bacterial infections the levels of
hladr
however comes down as infection
progresses
due to immune hydr in conjunction with
specific infection markers cd64 and
provides a snapshot valuable insight
into the timeline of infection immune
response
further decreased expression of hla dr
on monocytes is one of the best studied
markers of
sepsis induced immune separation
together
monocytic hladr and neutrophil cd64
form a potent combination of biomarkers
for an
accurate assessment of immune response
during
septic shock
with all this information a three color
panel has been
put together called the iotas myeloid
activation
with pv 169 pe
cd64 specific blue and
hla dr apc for visualizing the immune
response
during infection the flow cytometric
assay
can be used to visualize the different
aspects of
innate immune response during infections
it is a ready to use pre-mixed and
titrated cocktail
it's rapid and easy to use just add
blood
the antibody cocktail and versafix lysis
solution
to the tube and vortex the sample is
ready for acquisition in 10 minutes
there are no washing or centrifugation
steps
as you can see the fluorochromes are on
three different lasers
which means no compensation is required
which makes the analysis really easy
our r d team has collaborated with a
number of international groups
to generate publications which show the
utility
of these markers cd 169 cd64 and hladr
in visualizing the interferon and immune
response during infections
our data demonstrates that the upper
regulation of these
markers is very specific to the type of
interferons used
as seen from the figures in vitro
experiments
showed that type 1 interferon
specifically induced
the expression of cd169 on monocytes
and not interferon gamma which is a type
2 interferon
similarly interferon type 2 that is
interferon gamma
upregulates neutrophil cd64 expression
specifically and not any of the other
interferon alphas or betas
the two markers are thus able to
differentiate the interferon response
in a rapid procytomatic test
further when these markers were used in
the analysis of blood from
patients presenting with fever the
hospital emergency department
we observed that monocytic cd169
and neutrophil series 64 were effective
biomarkers for the differential
infection immune response as you can see
in the flow cytometry plots
there is an over expression of cv169
on monocytes in the case of viral
infection
while bacterial infections led to an
over expression of
neutrophil cd64
analysis of a cohort of 138 patients
entering the emergency department of the
larsen
hospital marseille france showed that
the quantitation
of the two biomarkers by pro cytometry
the mfi values
as shown in the y-axis was effective
in differentiating bacterial and viral
infections
as can be seen in the plots the cohorts
had a wide range of bacterial and viral
diseases
because these markers can be used as
generic markers of
bacterial and vinyl infections
several other cell surface biomarkers
were also tested
in this patient quart neutrophil cd64
was observed to distinguish wide variety
of bacterial infections
with high accuracy monocytic cd169
was not a significant marker for
bacterial infections as
was expected
with the iota's myeloid activation we
have a rapid
pro cytometric test for visualizing
the differential immune response to
bacterial and virulence
the panel can be used in multiple
research areas
such as interferon signaling antibiotic
resistance
viral disease progression and many
others
it can be an effective essay to study
the innate immune response and
interferon signaling during infections
inflammatory diseases the kinetics of
interferon release and characterization
of the different interferon classes in
various disease states
can be performed easily which is useful
not only in the understanding of
the innate immune response but also the
activation of the adaptive response
rapid identification of bacterial
infection
essential in understanding and combating
antibiotic resistance
further the panel can be used in the
development of biomarkers and new
antibiotics
type 1 interferons play an important
role in viral
infection and progression markers such
as cd 169
is very effective for studying the
dynamics
of interferon response during viral
infection
we are in the middle of a covet pandemic
number of publications have shown
the effectiveness of interferon
signaling as a biomarker of
sars cov2 infection and kovid disease
several transcriptomics analysis have
shown
interferon signaling and the induction
of
expression of interferon stimulated
genes isgs
as an important signature of sars kovi
to infection
like these examples from the analysis of
myeloid cells
the bowel fluid of covid patients
showing the expression of
numerous interferon signaling these is
at the top of the list
the study also looked at the expression
of interferon 1 response
isgs and the direct measurement of
intercrown levels
covet patients who are stratified
according to the severity of the disease
there is an increase in the intercurrent
type 1 response
upon infection however interestingly
the interferon response significantly
decreases
with the progression of the disease to
more severe manifestations
thus monocytic cd169 can be an
effective biomarker for sarcome to
infection
and for following this progression in
covent as it's a very good marker for
type one in the front
so how does the myeloid activation assay
work with sars cov2 infection
studies performed by our collaborators
in the ce2 montpelier france
on 53 patients in the covid emergency
unit
showed that monocytic cd169
by procytometry was highly correlated
with
covet positive positivity with qpcr
this rapid flow cytometric assay
can be effectively used to identify
covet positive cases
who can be confirmed with tcr this study
was recently published in the journal of
infectiousness
another study in the chu marseille
france
with 155 patients confirmed these
results
in another publication the flow
cytometric
assessment of different monocytic
markers
in a large cohort of covet cases showed
very good correlation of cd169
and hladr on monocytes with disease
onset and progression
as seen earlier there is an increase in
monocytic cd169 with infection
which drops down as the disease
progresses or with disease clearance
with the iotas myeloid activation we
have a rapid
easy to use test for visualizing the
early stages of infection
a snapshot of the innate immune response
we can effectively differentiate between
the bacterial
and viral infection immune response and
have a good idea of the interferon
signaling during infections
the test is easy to use a single step no
wash
no compensation and a rapid assay
the data and publications were generated
with our collaborations with
key cooperation partners in france in
germany
in the hospitals in marseille leon
pompeo and in berlin germany
here's the ordering information for the
kit
thank you for your attention and i am
ready for it
thank you very much
thank you shankar for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
our first question is
what do you think is the real advantage
or breakthrough with this
essay
shankar can you hear me
okay shankar i'm going to ask you a
question and i want you to
answer it if you can hear me
what do you think the real advantage or
breakthrough
with this assay
okay so uh
okay shane carl i'm going to ask the
question again
what do you think is the real advantage
or breakthrough with this assay
can you hear me
can you hear me can you hear me yeah i
can hear you now yeah
okay shall i read the question again
yes yes please thank you okay
what do you think is the real advantage
or breakthrough with this assay
hi so the i think the real breakthrough
the real
importance of this essay is that there
are not many
assays available to study the activated
myeloid cells
or even the innate immunity during
infection
so this is a sort of a black box and
even if you have assays they're
complicated to do
so with a simple flow cytometry test we
can quickly have an idea of what's
happening
to the immune system during infection
that's number one
second is again for interferon signaling
it's pretty difficult to actually have
an idea of what's happening
to what are the inflammatory processes
uh
during infection and other
[Music]
during infection and this is again a
quick and uh easy essay to look at or
have a snapshot of what's happening
there
and i think these are the two main
points i think i would like to emphasize
with this essay that
you're able to have an idea of what's a
glimpse of what's happening in
relatively
so most tests are usually with the
adaptive immune system the t
cell b cell response antibody response
but this is little bit
difficult to actually have an idea about
okay thank you so much i've got another
question for you
can this test be used to study other
inflammatory diseases such as autoimmune
diseases
yes there are so so
i've spoken mainly about uh i've spoken
mainly about infection response and all
those things but
this can be used to study the innate
immune system
in in a wide variety of conditions
and uh the best studied uh
of the conditions are of course the
autoimmune diseases the inflammation
during autoimmune disease
so recently there's been a publication
which has shown
that series 169 can be a very good
marker for
systemic lupus electromatosis and also
in the
in in
disease and even in in systemic lupus
erythrometers they show that
there's an increase in the cd169 levels
along with the disease
progression and can be used as a good
marker for disease progress
and even when the patients are treated
with hydroxychloroquine you see an
observer
you can observe a reduction in 3d 169
corresponding with clinical improvement
so it's actually a very good marker or a
good
way of monitoring autoimmune diseases
and all
information associated with ct's kind of
countries
for example yeah
okay great thank you so much i have
another question what happens when you
have both
viral and bacterial infection at the
same time
yeah so what you would actually see is
both of them will get upregulated both
cd169 and cd64 will be upregulated
uh when you have both the infections
there
in and it and since the specific this is
both the markers are very specific so
you can actually be
sure that both infections are present no
it's not a non-specific
upregulation of a marker
during this
what about testing children and infants
where other testing methods might be
difficult to use
yes so this is absolutely the i think
one of the big advantages
because it's a blood test so it has got
definite advantages over other uh
ways of you know sampling like you know
you know like a swab or different
to get access to the uh to the infection
site or
it's it's pretty complicated to do so a
simple blood test with the flow
cytometric
essay after that actually makes it very
easy to
test especially children and infants
because all you need is a drop of blood
uh the acid just requires 25 microliters
of blood
so uh this is a particularly i think
will be useful when we are doing
research or
looking at uh cases like that
okay and next question
is this a diagnostic test uh no
this is a research use only test
and should not be used for any
diagnostic purposes
what kind of research topics can you
envisage for
covid research yes
so uh as i've shown that people are
people have observed uh interferon
signaling is a pretty good marker for
covalent research that is at least to
look at
disease infection and disease
progression and even disease severity
and
so this could be a test i think uh which
can uh be used for studying
the the role of different cell types
studying the role of uh you know
different treatment reviews
what's happening to the covet symptoms
and i think uh this is because
the current test is actually uh what's
called a
it's it's a pcr test so you're measuring
only whether there's presence or absence
of
the virus but you're not seeing the
reaction of the body to it
and most of the other tests which are
done for doing that are basically
physiological parameters
so here with this this you are able to
look at the what is happening to the
immune system and how
the drugs vaccination and everything is
going to affect the immune system
and help it fight the infection
do you think there are applications for
this test in the present pandemic
oh yes i would still think that uh
pcr is the is the is the
gold standard test and the perfect test
for diagnosis
there is a lot of uh there is a scope to
use this test in monitoring patients
to look at how the patient's patients
are progressing
especially in hospitals
settings so this could be a a marker of
seeing whether the whether the disease
is progressing it's becoming severe the
patient needs more
radical treatment and also the
effectiveness of the vaccination process
so i think this can still be used to
measure those
kind of aspects in a research or in the
clinical research
i think
okay and other than people walking into
the doctor's office with a fever
what other settings do you think this
assay can be applied to
yeah i mean as i said so fever is one of
the
questions where they can do but you know
you can think of
mass screening of people so you can also
look at uh
places where you are like in workplaces
or
other public places where you are
thinking of
actually uh seeing whether the patient
is having currently having a
inspection and you want
that not to spread or you know the kind
of
quarantine measures and this can be a
quick way of also checking whether you
are
the patient is impacted or not uh to
have an idea
at least before a conformatory pcr is
done to
you know to be sure this is happening
and how do you overcome possible
non-specific staining
so uh that's a good question so we have
actually
the from the uh acid we have done and
from the type so first of all the
antibodies are titrated
so we have actually a very specific
concentration of the antibody into it so
that also is reducing the
non-specificity and the second thing is
cd 169 there is no expression
in normal sense so it's when you see an
increase in expression of kidney 169
you can be sure that it is an infection
it's a viral impact
can be pretty sure of that cd64 yes you
do have a little bit of
staining with cd64 even in
resting cells especially in the
neutrophils
so i mean because of monocytic cd64 it
is constitutive expressed so here we are
talking about
neutrophil cd64 you do have a
slight amount of expression but the upon
bacterial infection you have a very
clear over expression so i don't uh so
so far
in different clinical settings we have
seen we don't see
a problem of background savings
okay next question simple techniques
like pcr
or any such assays can also detect the
expression of
of genes like hla what is the advantage
of this assay in case of expression
analysis
is it in the perspective or sensitivity
and specificity
so uh so i think the biggest difference
is
is so
you know molecular tests are very good
because they
are very you can see what the expression
of the particular gene is
you can you can very accurately measure
that but
you really do not know what the
physiological
impact of it is so you can have an
expression of a particular cytokine or a
cytokine gene
or over expression of an interferon gene
in it but to know what the physiological
impact is what's happening
physiologically what's happening to the
immune cells
because of the over expression of it you
need
a cellular base essay so
that's the advantage of this essay
because it gives you a cellular idea it
tells you that okay hla dr there's an
increase
that means you see that there there the
the monocytes have been activated and
that's why you have an over expression
of of a atyl india same thing in a
in a in sepsis shock condition
you see a decrease in hladia because
you have an effect of the sepsis
information on it
this you might not directly correspond
with the gene expression of hldr
in the cell but this is the
physiological
or the cellular condition
so i think that's the advantage of
having a pro cytometry test where we are
measuring the physiological impact
okay next question what is the positive
predictive value for covalent 19
of this test yeah so again uh let me
be very clear there's a research use
only uh
so we cannot use it for diagnosis of
code
and it's not a specific test so you
understand this is for all viral
infections
but this can actually help you in
screening
or it can help you in actually looking
at patients
so you can actually do a stream to see
how many of them are positive and you
can do a further confirmation with pcr
so this is the advantage of this and as
you can see from the publications where
in the clinical research setting they
have looked at
qpcr's data and the tv 169 expression
they see a very very high correlation
between the two
so the publications are there so you can
actually go to the publications and
read i think the specificity and
everything is you know even mentioned so
you have
this data in detail out there
and can you use a finger stick for the
blood sample
actually yes you can use a finger brick
for the
uh for the blood sample so
so again assistance is the research
usually kit
so you need to standardize your methods
we cannot tell you that this is
exactly the way to do it so you need to
do a little bit of standardization
but as you can see from the publication
so
during the development of the assay we
did
study fingerprint blood so like like
with a
glance to take a drop of blood and the
assay you can perform with it and you
have very clear demarcation of the three
cell populations and
so it can be very easily used with a
fingerprint flood also
it needs to be standardized in your lab
okay thank you so much next question
can this assay be used to understand the
role of tumor
microenvironment to identify the related
biomarkers
[Music]
it is uh i actually have to
think about so it is little bit
complicated in this because
we are looking at circulated circulatory
cells
so this mainly cells which are actually
uh
you know circulatory of in cells in the
blood
so to measure what's happening in the
tumor biomarker would be difficult
but that said if we can
actually so if you can access the tumor
side
side so suppose you're doing uh you are
having uh so
if you can actually the tumor site you
can get a clinical sample
then you can actually measure this you
can actually see the activated myeloid
cells in that
place but you will have to access the
site you cannot use blood
okay shankar we have time for one more
question
um how can we set up the cutoff for the
cd64 neutrophils over
expression and if there is a link
between the severity of infection
and the degree of that over expression
okay this is a very good question uh so
uh actually it's so the only way to set
up the cd64 neutrophil expression in
in in
for bacterial infection is to follow the
infection
and so basically you need a gold
standard test that is either
what you call antibiotics or either the
clinical follow-up of the patient or
or a microbiological test to confirm
that it's the bacteria
and with that you can actually set up
the cd64 ecstasy
i'm not too sure whether we can directly
quantify
the severity of the infection
i don't think the two markers are
directly linked to one another
but i think you need more data for it
definitely but so far i don't think it
exists out there
well thank you again shankar for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckman culture life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye